Yahya runs a new Mexican restaurant in a
trendy street in Tel Aviv but less than
a year after he opened his business the
war on Gaza began although the
government has promised support to small
Ventures he hasn't received anything the
rules that you need like to have more
than one year to see what you work
before the previous year and they give
you
person and I don't have one year a lot
of small business closed already because
they didn't have uh the help and uh not
a lot of work we have here three or four
uh uh restaurants and Min markets that
already don't
work as part of a new amended budget the
government has promised money for
companies that have run out of funds
during the war a survey by the Central
Bureau of Statistics in November found
one in three startup businesses have
closed those that remain open reported
significant losses streets like this in
Tel Aviv are predominantly made up of
small businesses and some of the owners
which include reserved soldiers tell us
they feel neglected by the government
and they're not being properly
compensated for the loss of business and
staff during the war they also say
they're skeptical that the new budget
will fill the
void but many economists say the
government's priorities are skewed as
money funneled to religious schools and
illegal settlement projects remain
intact and small businesses are not
being prioritized one of the things that
I think many politicians and economists
do not understand that it's not enough
to allocate 12 billion for a certain
cause you must have a mechanism that
actually takes the money and funnels it
down and funnels it quickly in Israel we
do not appreciate enough small
businesses we look down at them and
that's a big big big mistake because
these are the businesses actually drive
the
economy Maya understands this all too
well she's been a TV theater and
children's entertainer for 25 years now
she struggles to put food on the table
the worst was the minute it started
because the diary was full booked so we
came from 100% work to
0% I know it's small stuff but when you
don't have money to buy food you start
starting to be
nervous I even starting to lose my
voice uh get stressed you know like and
I couldn't sleep small business owners
like Maya says it's the workingclass and
poor who are bearing the economic costs
of the war and are also being forgotten
Laura Khan Al jazer Tel
Aviv Stephanie deer joins us now from
occupied East Jerusalem and Steph it
does seem that sort of various parts of
Israeli Society are either not happy or
or critical of the government be it the
media small businesses or just parts of
the Israeli public depending on who you
talk
to yes well to give you an example this
deal uh to get medicine to the captives
inside Gaza which really the Israeli
government wanted to be hailed a success
particularly Benjamin Netanyahu who
issued a statement around 5 days ago
saying that it was him who had tossed
the mad with go going to K with a deal
to get these medicines to the hostages
well that only really transpired
yesterday as to the details israelies
woke up to some of the main headlines uh
first of all here the baby this is the
youngest captive um inside Gaza he turns
one today so this is pressure on the
government having him on the front page
saying 104 Days Later his family has
done everything to try to get him out
and the headlines very critical actually
of this medicine deal you have another
of the main newspapers saying bitter
medicine why is that and the headlines
talking about the fact that this deal
actually showed the mess in quotes in
the security establishment the fact that
Benjamin Netanyahu was so eager to
announce the deal I just referred to
that about four or five days ago and
that his defense minister yav Galant
yesterday only found out from a Hamas
official that according to this deal
initially Israel was not going to
inspect those a trucks with the medicine
now this is something that Israel always
insists upon it is pretty unheard of uh
to have uh trucks going into Gaza that
aren't inspected by Israel so as we saw
unfold and as we reported yesterday
those Aid trucks were ready to go then
because of the uh outroar in the
security establishment they then went uh
to be inspected by Israel only then to
be allowed into Gaza so the irony here
is that Benjamin Netanyahu already is
under incredible fire first of all I
don't think Israelis will ever forgive
him for the events of October the
um they do hold him responsible he has
never taken any of that on board but it
now is real a real backlash as the
details are unfolding as to how that uh
deal went on and many people in the
highest elements didn't know about these
kinds of facts so this is the mood here
and you mentioning there that a lot of
people are criticizing yes particularly
the hostage families also tens of
thousands of people you see them
protesting in Tel Aviv every weekend say
that this government is not doing more
to bring the captives back uh that the
war is not going to course that they
don't seem to know what they are doing
and I think these calls as time goes on
and as people get more and more worried
for the lives of the captives those
calls of criticism will keep increasing
Stephan DEA there for us in occupied
East Jerusalem thanks Steph